I understand that the name of the
suicide bomber who we've been told went
and studied in the UK is Abdul Latif
Jameel Mohammed I have had that name
confirmed from a security source here a
security source back in the UK and my
colleague Alistair Banco has also had
that name confirmed from one of his
sources so we're very confident that the
name is correct now we understand that
this individual went to the UK back in
2006 2007 time to study and he spent
time in the South East of England in
terms of his role in the attack that's
not completely clear but it seems as
though he was the bomber that was not
involved in the the main attack against
the three churches and the three hotels
but he was the suicide blast that went
off a few hours later by a small hotel
in the dehiwala area of Colombo okay we
have heard I know you did an interview
with the Prime Minister yesterday didn't
you and he gave you the information that
not all parts of government knew what
was going on with the information that
was being provided by the security
services
yes exactly yeah it was it was a press
conference and he he entertained quite a
few of my questions
and yes that he was fully admitting that
there's been intelligence failures here
and the authorities were tipped off by
the the Indian intelligence services
back on April the 4th so more than two
weeks before the attack that a plot was
in the making to target churches and
despite that clear warning and that kind
that information for some reason or
another was not circulated it would seem
amongst the highest excellence of the
Sri Lankan government the president said
he was not aware and the prime minister
said he was not aware and under
ministers have also said that they were
not aware and today we've learned that
the national security chief and the head
of Defence of the Defence Forces has
been has been fired
we were told but
you know there would be resignations as
a result of this but it's really shaken
people's confidence the idea that
potentially lives could have been saved
if people had known in advance that
there was this threat of such an attack
they could have taken precautions
perhaps even cancelling Easter Sunday
services and we also have learned from
yesterday is like the Islamic state
group claiming responsibility and
releasing this propaganda video that
showed eight men we think they are the
suicide attackers pledging allegiance to
the the is chief and it is here have not
confirmed that that is that the claim is
authentic
but sources say they don't have any
reason to doubt the credibility and if
it is confirmed that Islamic state was
behind this attack
then that would mark the biggest single
terrorist attack by that group outside
Iraq and Syria and that's particularly
significant coming a month after the
fall of the so-called Caliphate in Syria
and really does show demonstrate that
people's worst fears are true while the
Caliphate has gone the threat is still
there